Was wäre wenn man ein terabyte informationen auf einem fingernagel
unterbringen könnte oder noch besser ein terabyte auf wenigen nanometern also millionstel millimetern der absolute wahnsinn
skorpionen sollen das ermöglichen das sind wirbel in magnetischen materialien die tatsächlich das zeug dazu haben unsere
datenspeicher und damit die computer zu revolutionieren das zeigen jetzt auch aktuelle forschungsergebnisse
Aus halle wie genau
funktionieren skorpionen welche unfassbaren vorteile sie haben das jetzt im krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Früher waren es beispielsweise
disketten oder usb sticks auf denen man dateien videos und fotos gespeichert hat heutzutage
Lädt man einfach alles in einer cloud und kann von überall
auf der welt darauf zugreifen letztendlich sind ja aber auch hier die daten auf riesigen festplatte abgespeichert und zwar meistens in großen
datencentern von unternehmen wie google facebook apple und so weiter technisch gesehen
werden die einzelnen daten bis durch einen mechanischen schreib und lesekopf mit
magnetfeld pulsen auf eine schnell rotierende scheibe also die festplatte geschrieben das ist immer noch die gängige weil
preiswerteste methode doch diese herkömmliche
speichertechnik wird in zukunft wohl an ihre grenzen stoßen denn immer mehr
Daten sollen auf immer weniger raum gespeichert werden und ein erster schritt sind ja die ssds
heiße kandidaten für eine fortentwicklung das sind diskussionen
gemeint ist ein spezielles magnetisches phänomen das schon vor mehr als 25 jahren vom physiker und physikerinnen
theoretisch vorhergesagt worden ist und vor einigen jahren dann sind diese magnetischen wirbel die sich wie teilchen verhalten
experimentell in magnetischen materialien nachgewiesen worden sie haben viele eigenschaften die uns in sachen moderner datenspeicherung extrem
nützlich sein könnten sie sind stabil
sie können sehr klein sein an durchmesser von nur wenigen nanometern und sie lassen sich durch geringe elektrische ströme
erzeugen und manipulieren ein speicherchip auf scream ionen basis könnte also deutlich energie und platzsparender gebaut werden als herkömmliche
Datenspeicher seite seinem forschungsteam aus den usa im jahr 2015 zum ersten mal gelungen ist millionen
bei, zimmertemperatur zu erzeugen und zu manipulieren
Gelten sie als sehr sehr viel versprechende zukunftstechnologie ein forschungsteam aus halle hat jetzt neue berechnung zu den kommunen
Angestellt ihr ziel ist es speichermedien robuster kleiner und bis zu 1000 mal schneller zu machen
einer der beteiligten ist physiker alexander schäffler zitat das besondere an diesen quasi teilchen ist dass sie sich in einem sehr stabilen
topologische geschützten zustand befinden und daher eine geringe anfälligkeit gegenüber externen einflüssen die temperaturen oder
erschütterungen aufweisen doch die stabilität der skorpion ist auch ein nachteil weiß das forschungsteam
Aus halle dadurch sind sie nur schwer zu erzeugen und dann zudem noch schwer
zu verändern weil sich die sgo millionen aber wie teilchen verhalten könnten die speicherung von daten sehr viel schneller passieren als
Wir es bislang kennen und zwar innerhalb von pikosekunden also dem
billionstel einer sekunde also in quasi nichts der absolute wahnsinn das ist unfassbar viel schneller als heute möglich
Komplett neue anwendungen werden dadurch möglich ich sage nur künstliche intelligenz, im binären code
Des computers könnten sie für 10 stehen denn obwohl für millionen sehr stabil sind könnten sie mit hilfe von
Elektronenstrahlen ihre ausrichtung verändern sie entstehen spontan oder können in schicht system
Erzeugt werden in denen sich magnetische filme befinden die wiederum die größe von etwa einem nanometer haben
wechselwirkung die sich zwischen schwermetallen wie wolfram oder platin und einem ferro magneten bilden lasse millionen entstehen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler weltweit denken über bauteile mit nano plättchen nach auf denen vier millionen
Angeordnet sind so müsste sich an dem grundgerüst der geräte von heute überhaupt nicht viel ändern ein rotierender lese und schreib kopf könnte dann die
zustände der skorpion auslesen oder auch ändern den berechnungen
Aus halle zufolge würden wohl rund sieben milliarden spam millionen auf die fläche einer cent münze passen
umgerechnet entspricht das etwa einem gigabyte an informationen und
die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler hoffen sogar dass sie den radius in zukunft auf einige nanometer also ganz
verkleinern könnten das würde dann bedeuten dass man acht millionen
skorpionen unterbringen könnte umgerechnet also ein terabyte an
informationen und es gibt tatsächlich hoffnung darauf dass diese speichertechnologie in 15 bis 20 jahren
Zum einsatz kommen könnte absolut irre wenn er kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann würden wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die gore denn nur dann verpasst ihr kein weiteres video tier hier geht es weiter mit ihnen maß
künstliche intelligenz die größte gefahr für die menschheit
Da wird einem schon ein wenig angst und bange wenn es noch nicht gesehen habe dann unbedingt anschauen oder ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran